Sein mystischer Verbrecher und meine Fragen
wären, was hast du getan, bevor
du mit der Musik anfängst und warum du ähm, warum
bist du auf den Song Ayo Technology gekommen,
aber deine zweite Frage, die ich
im vorherigen vorherigen Film erklärt habe,
was habe ich gemacht, bevor ich  wurde
Musiker, seine Musik war immer ein sehr, sehr großer
Teil meines Lebens, und sobald ich
weiß nicht, ich glaube, es war 10, als ich
anfing, Musik zu spielen, als ich wirklich
anfing, Instrumente zu lernen,
war es immer da  aber und ich
brauchte einfach eine lange Zeit, sagen wir 15 Jahre,
um mich als Musiker und
Songwriter zu entwickeln, und ich musste langsam
besser werden, und während ich mir diese Zeit nahm
, um besser zu werden, habe ich andere Dinge getan, aber das
waren nicht wirklich Sie
Du weißt,
ich bin zur Schule gegangen, und als ich zur
Schule ging und als ich war, hast du
an meiner Musik gearbeitet, was ist ein Barkeeper, ich
habe viele Sommerjobs gemacht, ich meine, ich habe Restaurants geschrieben,
ich  arbeitete in einer
Aluminiumfabrik für am  onth ich was
weißt du sonst noch wie Verwaltungsjobs ich
weißt du nur ich habe all diese manchmal wirklich
beschissenen Jobs gemacht, aber für mich waren das mit einem
ganz klaren Ziel vor Augen, dir
anzufangen, eine neue Gitarre zu kaufen oder später
mein erstes Album zu bezahlen  und genau zu der Zeit,
als ich nicht mehr leugnen konnte,
dass ich einen richtigen Job finden musste, ich
nenne es genau zu dieser Zeit, Anfang
2007, begann meine Karriere
in Belgien, und ich hatte großes Glück
und Gefühl  sehr privilegiert, Sie
vier Jahre lang in Vollzeit ausstellen zu können